hey here's just wacky video wisconsin
republican state senator glenn grothman
is not big on masks and he introduced
donald trump at the wisconsin state
republican convention on saturday
masks were of course optional only a few
masks in the crowd of hundreds of people
glenn showed up after tweeting pictures
of himself out and about earlier in the
day
not wearing a mask of course he shows up
and he tries to introduce donald trump
and he immediately goes into
an uncontrollable coughing fit the cough
racking his entire body the way
coronavirus is known to do
i believe at one point you actually hear
someone someone shout from the crowd are
you okay
you have to see it to believe it he
actually has to start loosening his tie
because of the degree to which he's
coughing violently
it's time to talk about donald j trump
[Applause]
okay
yep okay guys this is how coronavirus
spreads i'm not saying he has
coronavirus
but it spreads when anti-masked people
are around other people all day and then
they're coughing in public
i'm not saying that cough i don't know
how close people were sitting maybe
that cough doesn't give it to anybody
but wisconsin is increasingly in trouble
if you look at their case numbers
cases are spiking hitting their highest
seven day moving average
today with four days in a row of record
high cases
now the event organizers are saying
or they said earlier if you have
symptoms you shouldn't go
the event organizer said we will make
available
face masks for people who want them
almost nobody wore a mask
in comes this guy and he's coughing
uncontrollably
you really can't fix stupid and this is
why we aren't making progress
and i know people i already said it
people are going to write and say david
you know this this guy probably doesn't
have coronavirus
layer one is even having this event you
just shouldn't have this event there's
no reason to have this event right now
layer two if you have the event require
the masks say that the masks are
required
i guess that's considered taking away
people's freedoms on the republican side
and then layer three is this specific
guy
coughing uncontrollably he's an invited
speaker
not wearing a mask and he's setting the
model
that it's okay to be going around in
public coughing with no mask it's
stunning
stunning idiocy the likes of which we
hopefully will never see again
in leadership in this country trump
finally wore a mask over the weekend
and i i hope to talk about that tomorrow
but you know the the trump people are
now
they're all over the place on trump
wearing the mask the people who think
masks aren't necessary don't know how to
react because trump now is wearing one
is trump stupid to wear it
then there's the people who think that
the masks or something the left is
bullying people into if they see trump
wearing it by definition trump must not
really be that alpha because he was
bullied by the left into wearing a mask
if trump insists the pandemic is over
why did he just now
start wearing a mask his followers are
completely flummoxed by trump wearing
the mask but
this is all part of the big picture it's
setting
a model uh for for what it is that
people should and shouldn't be doing and
glenn grothman here
hacking uncontrollably not good not good
whatsoever if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off
a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com slash
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video